and let's talk a little bit about kind
of this creator economy
um it's really interesting to me how uh
it's almost like creators are
the new small business right and what
we're seeing is
uh take the sub stack you know kind of
revolution if you will there's much
people leaving
uh and now they've got this ability to
uh kind of do it you know one version of
where
you could you really started with like
this membership model do you
see those people trying to build out
actual businesses or is this just a
where
writers want to get paid to write right
and what i keep going back to is this
idea of
is there a separation between kind of
people who want to build a business and
people who want to just create
or are we going to see kind of the rise
of the hybrid right the people who
want to create things but also um have
the ambition and the skill set to
actually build
businesses as like the ceo as well yeah
listen i think that's sort of the
conundrum that i'm in right now right
it's like um i want to upm to be a media
company not a person
and so i've built strategies around that
uh
with sub stack in particular obviously
you're very familiar with it
um i think that the vast majority of the
the top users are individuals they are
building
their own creator pipelines they're not
necessarily
building media companies i think it's
hard
to build a media company on sub stack
obviously there are a few exceptions
and those exceptions might be growing in
the in the near future
but um but it's it's hard so
i think with casey newton for instance
today right like you see him
as a as one heck of a journalist like
that's
you will make a lot of money as an
individual journalist
um i'm
i think it's different than the
alternative which is
i think that i forgot the name but the
group from deadspin that launched on
substance a few a few weeks ago
do you remember the name i don't but i
know who you're talking about so
i think there's 30 of them and they are
i think they is this defector
yes yes they so 20 000 something
subscriptions uh which is insane
so that's sort of the dichotomy right
there there's the individual
and then there's sort of the the
umbrella where
do you hear you hear defector but you
don't notice well
i can't name a single journalist that's
actually writing for defector but it's a
very
uh valuable organization that could
potentially
believe substance and do its own thing
and have just just as much
success i think that's the difference
right but can you
can you build an audience can you build
a structure around employing the right
people
and can you port that audience elsewhere
on your own url
and with your own design with your own
logo work to build a media company
i think that's sort of like the the mark
that determines that yeah and we've
obviously seen this before with like the
buzzfeed and they came out with buzzfeed
products right and kind of put it
through
um and one of my favorite examples uh
and then the name's gonna escape me now
but uh they do the really in-depth um
product reviews like if there's a watch
that says you know it's 30 meters
kind of water resistant they literally
put it on and go 30 meters down in the
water and make sure that it uh
it does it but those types of
organizations have found
multiple ways to monetize uh but they
have large staffs right
they're kind of well funded in this
creator economy
we're almost seeing people start
businesses
from scratch with no funding in most
cases maybe there's some kind of
personal funding that they're you know
putting towards it
but but it really does feel like we're
getting back to this idea of like
the only people who are going to survive
and have the option or possibility of
thriving
or the people who find product market
fit right because they're going to use
the the
revenue to basically fuel anything else
they want to do is that
directionally correct do you think it is
i mean i think there are a number of
companies i'm not trying to sell anyone
short because i've seen it happen myself
there are a number of companies that
started small
and have quite a substantial footprint
on the industry i think an example is
probably
one of my stops i mean uncrate is
probably
a great example because you know i don't
know what the what the
payroll is but they they have no more
than 15 people
right now and if you compare them to
much much larger
organizations with 60 or even 100 people
the output looks the same
well that company started with one
person doing one thing right
and it sort of scaled up from there so
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna belittle
anyone that starts off as one person
because clearly that's the same way that
i started i just know that
to build an actual sort of
um to build brain equity i think we have
to focus more on um
inanimate brand and not the person
behind it
i think that's that's the key difference
in in in the creator economy today